tallying up the losses from Hurricane
Ian has only just begun our roof is in
the back of the house
for these retirees seeing the damage to
their homes and neighborhood was
overwhelming there's no words for it
it's like holy cow what a mess the
Southwest coast of Florida took the
brunt of wind and storm surge but the
impact of the heavy rainfall was felt
further Inland and up the United States
eastern coast
experts say wetter storms is One impact
of climate change the majority of the
cost as well as the lives lost as a
result of hurricanes and tropical
Cyclones comes from flooding it comes
from storm surge it comes from the
rainfall
one of the costliest storms in U.S
history superstorm Sandy wasn't even a
hurricane by the time it got here in New
York and yet here's where it did the
most damage 82 billion dollars in
flooding and infrastructure costs some
early estimates for Hurricane Ian are
approaching that
more than 40 thousand utility workers
were dispatched to Florida alone to help
restore power water mains and roads have
also suffered extensive damage not to
mention Bridges the governor said 800 of
them were in need of assessment
President Biden declared a disaster in
Florida Paving the way for federal
assistance for infrastructure as well as
individuals it means the federal
government will provide individual
assistance of 37 900 for home repairs
another thirty seven thousand nine
hundred dollars for lost property for
everything from the automobile to a lost
wedding ring with several Health Care
Facilities damaged and forced to
evacuate Health impacts and related
costs will take years to fully
understand and it's gone
in the Flash
while the human costs remain
incalculable
Kristin salumi Al Jazeera New York